[Music]
baby pull me closer in the back seat of
Europe the chainsmokers have been all
over the radio since 2014 but believe it
or not they've never actually released
an album that is until today we've been
sitting on a lot of these songs for a
long time and I'm just time to rug
here's them
in Paris Paris is just one of the songs
on their debut record memories do not
open tomorrow the grammy award winning
duo will perform on Saturday Night Live
and today we were with them in New York
City as they brought to life the bedroom
on the album's cover art and invited
fans to stop by the pop-up to meet them
they're really just asking for selfies
yeah there's an in-depth questions guys
they always have the SNL after-party
which is like infamous so I'm excited I
just heard about this today from him you
go back to Miami for our tour rehearsal
we have a big tour coming up like 39
shows in 39 cities and different arenas
and going straight back and rehearsals
and started work on the next album
[Music]